Good morning, Hank, it's Sunday. 100 questions, 4 minutes. Go!
"How many puffs would a puff puff if a puff could puff puff?" Six.
"What kind of dog is Willie?" The barky kind.
"How will the world end?"
Whimper not bang.
"Favorite picture book?"
Little Pea in your pants.
"Do you like your bobble head?"
[Rattling]
"Nikon or Canon?"
Canon.
"Favorite Disney movie?"
Fantasia.
"Would you ever get a cat?"
The Yeti's allergic.
"Favorite year of high school?"
Senior.
"Will Paper Towns be published in France?"
Je pense que oui.
"Are you a ninja?"
Hi-yaaaa!
Oh...
Ah
No.
"Cheese?"
"Height?"
6'1".
"Who the eff is Hank?"
He's a massive, incandescent gas.
"How long have you had the puff?"
Long time.
"Favorite Hank song?"
Anglerfish.
"Can I hug you?"
Not right now, I'm answering questions.
"Why?"
Because I said so.
"New Star Wars trilogy or old trilogy?"
Come on.
"Big Macs or Whoppers?"
Fitness challenges.
"Where is the puppy?"
"Do you like apples?"
"Favorite band?"
The Mountain Goats.
"Second favorite band?"
Still the Mountain Goats.
"Third favorite band?"
Hank.
"Fourth favorite band?"
Then back to the Mountain Goats.
"Favorite shirt?"
"Paper or plastic?"
Tote bags.
"Favorite scent?"
White Musk
"Did you like the Hunger Games?"
Yes.
"Argyle?"
Double yes.
"What's next?"
"Favorite city?"
Amsterdam.
"First job?"
Steak and Shake.
"Ikea bookshelves?"
[rattling]
"Star Wars or Star Trek?"
Will you write a sequel to Looking For Alaska?
Probably not.
"Did you like Kenyon?"
[rattling]
"Wait, when?"
April.
"Joyce or Yeats?"
Joyce.
"Video editing software?
Final Cut.
"Anagram of 11 + 2?"
12 + 1, riddle pwned.
"Link or Mario?"
Mario.
"What's the meaning of life?"
Other people.
"Why do you sweat so much?"
It's hot.
"Favorite time period?"
Now.
"Are you worried about balding?"
Jeez, I wasn't until you mentioned it.
But now I am.
"Can you speak Klingon?"
[Speaking Klingon]
Alaska, Lindsay or Margo?
Mmmmargo.
"Unstoppable force or unmovable object?"
Force.
"Who?"
Monkeys.
"What?"
Monkeys!
"Where?!"
In your pants!
"When?!"
Now!
"Why?!"
I don't know, you got some bananas in there or something?
"What's a question?"
It's like a statement only it ends like this?
"Faulkner or Whitman?"
Whitman.
"Briefs or boxers?"
Boxers.
"Favorite arcade game?"
Nerdfighters.
"You wish you had a different name?"
There's a guy in the US Marines whose real name is Lance Corporal Max Fightmaster.
I wouldn't mind being Lance Corporal Max Fightmaster.
"Worst president?"
Buchanan.
"Ketchup or mustard?"
nom nom nom nom nom nom
ahhhhh
KETCHUP
Actually not that good as a main course.
"Sox or yankees?"
Cubs.
"Favorite type of pie?"
The mathematical constant type.
"What's your favorite word?"
Together.
"The accidental onion ring in your Burger King fries -
annoying distraction or pleasant surprise?"
Pleasant surprise.
"Favorite play?"
Hamlet.
"Where's Waldo?"
By the cotton candy.
"What's up?"
Not much,
I'm just trying to answer 100 questions in 4 minutes.
"Favorite teacher?"
First grade, Miss Newton.
"One thing you can't live without?"
Water.
"Who loves you, baby?"
My mom?
"Favorite Beatle?"
John.
"Favorite color?"
Green.
See- see what I did there?
"Monet or Manet?"
Manet.
zoo
"Near or far sighted?"
Near.
"How's the weather?"
"Do you like pizza?"
"Am I too nerdy?"
"Do you like your iPhone?"
"Worst impulse buy?"
Sunny, yes, no, yes and this shirt.
"Pie or cake?"
Pake.
"Who's your hero?"
This guy.
"Glasses prescription?"
About that.
"Favorite veggie?"
nom nom nom nom nom
"Picard or Kirk?"
Picard.
"Muffins?"
Yes.
"Nirvana?"
Sure.
"Hope or despair?"
Hope.
"Am I cool?"
You're jokes.
"Colin or Q?"
Q!
"Lefty?"
Righty.
"Do you love me?"
Yes.
"Are you happy? Almost.
"Is this the last question?"
No.
"Is THIS the last question?"
Yes!
I'll see you on Tuesday.
[pants]
Ugh I am a hot mess.